kirst armor was darting around on a
whole range of subjects today accusing
the government of flip-flopping on
policy in a week where the PM bent to
Tory rebellions on housing and onshore
wind there was another U-turn last night
this time on wind farms actually I agree
with that one but it's the no issue on
which he won't give in to his back
benches the blancmange Prime Minister
wobbles
[Applause]
it is a grubby deal with a handful of
his MPS and sold out the aspirations of
those who want to own their own home
once again to portray the PM as weak
I tell him what is weak it's not being
look at the labor benches here
it was a news EPM cues Richie sunak
tried to tie the labor party to the
unions and committed to introduce new
strike laws if the union leaders to
continue to be unreasonable then it is
my duty to take action to protect the
lives and livelihoods of the British
public and that's why Mr Speaker since I
became prime minister I have been
working for new tough laws to protect
people from this disruption
there has been pressure from his own
side on this but tougher strike laws
have been talked about for years it's
something Liz truss and Boris Johnson
were looking at it won't help with the
immediate threat on Michelle Moon the
peer under attack over covered contracts
the PM had this like everyone else I was
absolutely shocked to read about the
allegations
it's absolutely right
[Applause]
it's it's absolute it's absolutely right
that she is no longer attending the
House of Lords and therefore no longer
has the conservative whip the Lord's
whip then clarified that because she's
taken a leave of absence she
automatically lost the whip
and there was a new face in the Commons
today the labor MP for Chester after the
worst Tory results since 1832. as for
the SMP the New Westminster leader
Stephen Flynn greeted outgoing leader
Ian Blackford and in his Commons debut
an immediate slight on the PM's personal
wealth in Mr Speaker far be it for me to
offer advice to her near billionaire but
he's going to have to up his game and
here's why because in the last 15
minutes a poll has landed which shows
the support for Scottish independence
has now hit 56 percent
foreign
his predecessor Ian Blackford left the
chamber to a warm handshake from Tori
Andrew Mitchell there was Blue on Blue
from a former leadership hopeful we were
one of the hardest hit errors in Medway
during covert 19. we need our fair share
allocation of resources and out of the
Jungle into the commons Matt Hancock was
back for his first pmqs on the Tory
benches but he is out of the
Parliamentary party this afternoon
confirming he won't stand at the next
election
the chamber was pretty noisy
conservatives quick to cheer on the PM
but Rishi sunak is accused of blowing
with political pressure being at the
mercy of his own MPS and labor are on
the attack